[Music]
this week's 48 hours investigates the
murder of a texas man out on an early
morning walk with his wife and dog this
was october 2020 jamie faith gunned down
just moments after leaving his home in
dallas
after the tragedy their neighbors
rallied to raise money to help his wife
jennifer faith
48 hours correspondent peter van sant
shows us how authorities now say there
was a money link between jennifer faith
and her husband's alleged killer
it was the morning of october 9 2020 and
a security camera captured this haunting
photo of jamie and jennifer faith
heading out to walk their dog moments
later they came under fire and
neighborhood cameras captured the audio
[Music]
jennifer faith was unharmed but her
husband jamie an american airlines
manager died at the scene shot seven
times
three times to the head three times to
the chest and once to the groin
christy jack is a prominent defense
attorney we asked to review the case and
as soon as i saw it i thought that's a
hit
home security cameras captured images of
the killer's getaway truck it had a
white t sticker on the back window oh my
god
if you know what happened i need i need
that for closure i need to make some
sense out of this
jennifer faith publicly asked for help
and neighbors raised 60 thousand dollars
in a gofundme account
but authorities became suspicious when
they discovered jennifer was having an
emotional affair with daryn lopez her
high school sweetheart and they actually
conducted aerial surveillance of
darren's house
and lo and behold
there's this truck with the tee on the
back window the white tea the white tea
when investigators searched lopez's
house they found a gun with jamie's
blood on it they also found evidence
that jennifer was showering him with
cash and gifts using some of the money
from that gofundme account neighbor
jenna wilson was heartbroken do you feel
that you were taken advantage of it's
hard not to feel that way
but if you think this is a simple murder
for hire story you'd be wrong
there is no question that jennifer faith
was the puppet master and daryn lopez
was her puppet
peter van sant joins us now wow peter
so she's getting money through a
gofundme and giving it to the alleged
killer uh who is the puppet according to
that expert there we heard at the end um
how so what was the the dynamic between
the two well the experts that we
consulted during the course of our
investigation say she is one of the most
brilliant psychological manipulating
people they've ever dealt with in their
career she would create false identities
uh false email accounts send out emails
to this ex-boyfriend from from high
school claiming she was being physically
and sexually abused send out graphic
photos turned out of injury turned out
those photos were from a traffic
accident she'd had years earlier and
other images from the internet and over
the course of months and emotionally
appealing to him because he was a lonely
guy
he had some psychological problems she
weaponized him to murder her husband
clearly he had some psychological
problems it's astounding to me that he
would do that with no physical contact
with her i mean this is that caught up
with her it's a remarkable thing we were
talking about this and you mentioned how
it can be more powerful sometimes
emotional affair these distance affairs
well that was the case here was there
any evidence that she had been abused by
him by her husband there was no
she never went to a hospital
never told a friend no police reports
and she later admitted that he never
touched her he was a beloved member of
this why did she do that why did she
well people think it had to do with
money because she could inherit as much
as a million dollars from this guy but
one of the one of the experts that we
spoke to he thinks it was the game it
was the game this psychological game she
got such pleasure from it wow peter van
sant you can see the full report and i
clearly you're going to want to it's
called the plot to kill jamie faith on
48 hours tomorrow night 10 9 central
right here on cbs and streaming on
paramount plus